I'm seeing with Patrick hating Patrick
I'm just a song stage I godly to have
you here so this is very exciting for us
Ashley because and I'm sure even though
it's exciting for me is about 20 times
work sorry for you because you're about
to announce a brand new oculus project
Morpheus game that no one has ever seen
or heard about before that's right so I
get a pass over the young I stop talking
yes so what do we tell me and they'll
give people will know through this
conversation so we're we're announcing
today again called the assembly okay and
it's a game as you said for project
Morpheus an oculus rift it's a puzzle
adventure game really Richard venture
game of the rich with a really fantastic
story and we'll be there for launch of
both headsets Wow wonderful ok so tell
me I thought it a little bit of a sneak
peek of some of the things from the
trailer which we're about to watch
certainly hint said the the tone and the
setting but it all looks a bit sci-fi in
a bit morally questionable is that a
good assessment certainly morally
questionable yeah it's about the
assembly who this group of engineers and
scientists they've created this
underground underground bunker and we go
Noah fact yes so this is the underground
bunker and you basically you place a
couple of different characters in here
and you try to figure out what on earth
is going on these guys two experiments
that they wouldn't be allowed to do in
the real world that may be morally
questionable or actually against the law
but they think of from the benefit of
mankind and will actually ultimately
help people so you will try to figure
out what's happening down there you
plays a couple of different characters
and it's a really interesting really
strong story written by this guy called
Tom zubair who wrote FTL the swapper and
a few other really great guys penumbra
so it's a really good young writer and
it's a very powerful story that runs
through the game so this kind of wow
that did not go well for him this kind
of sci-fi it's not really side for this
kind of scientific lab aesthetic what
was your inspiration for this so what I
mean are you big people are going to
draw conclusions I think like Joe
comparison sorry to things like
half-life for example but what what are
your inspirations for this kind of
setting well we wanted to do something
something mysterious and we want to do
something that wasn't big and open well
because with VR we wanted to make sure
it runs you know 100 frames a second it
is super silky smooth so we thought and
we also wanted to make a game that was
not too fast paced for us VR is all
about exploration and
looking at an exploring a figure out
what's going on as solving puzzles so we
felt that this kind of interior setting
and an underground bunker seemed really
suitable for that where you were stuck
and you had to try and escape and you
have to figure out what was going on and
we can go from room to room from place
to place and try and figure out and
solve this this powerful story and solve
these puzzles so no load of puzzles in
there physics and with cameras we've got
binoculars microscopes lots of visual
stuff that works well with you so really
should i play with new ways of using VR
using absolutely yeah we spent a lot of
time messing around with your
experimenting and prototyping uncle you
know trying things to like you know what
happens when you wear glasses what
happens when it's cold and you breathe
and we got to for example two characters
that they're very different ones a lot
higher taller than the other and envy
are you really notice a height
difference you notice the fact that you
know you're close to the door you're
small nobody on another character you
notice of different sounds they make I
see you can see your avatar I can see
here when you're in yeah till you lose
oh this is a beginning of the game this
is just a small section of it but you're
basically being pushed in on a gurney
you're being wheeled in as one of the
character school Madeleine and you're
basically being pushed into this place
lately you're an initiative you may see
an installation initiation test to try
and check that you're you're good enough
to join the organization and to teach
you about it are we here under our own
or a free will or we've strapped to this
Stratton really they're like it's pretty
dark no no this is a really nice intro
to a VR game because feels very good for
at least another 3d it's a nice gentle
intro where you can look around you can
hear what's going on you can hear what
the characters are saying and then you
get knocked out and put into a cell and
then you start to learn about picking up
objects walking around solving puzzles
and using inventory and doing that kind
of stuff so that your boots on rails but
then after this is kind of dig you
control it with us absolutely yeah
you're going to be around as well okay
yeah we've got a lot of things hell in
there so it's really designed so you can
just explore and look and examine and
kind of figure out what's going on okay
now FM I've had a couple of objects use
oculus and Morpheus once um but the only
time I've used it and it's not made me
slightly wanna vomit yes when I was in
like a space plane for example Valkyrie
yeah so how do you guys go about making
sure that people don't throw out over a
year lovely science lab well we did a
lot of testing and I think one thing i
should say is that if you use a new g k2
or the Morpheus they both had positional
tracking
yes which helps an awful long so use
difference yeah we've got that matter
all right imagine is you know when
you're SAT here you almost always sway
left or right I'll move forward a bit
positional tracking really compensate
for that makes you means you see what
you expect to see and also a game is you
know very slow pace it's no rushing it's
no running there's no turning around 180
degrees super quickly you know shooting
at people it's it's a nice channel game
that your works really well with a VR
headsets it's like there's no combat in
this game it's all puzzle and there's no
combat there's no gun this is puzzle
based there's lots of tension there's
some scary stuff it's a bird to go this
and fear but there's no no come back so
it's horror like a big thrill yeah kind
of thrilling situation scary situations
video part it's definitely not a horror
game with creatures and monsters but
there are psychological horror objects
it's kind of like what on earth are they
doing in this lab type of horror very
much so yeah and some really tough moral
choices as well so as a player you know
you really are we're questioning where
your lines are what you would do and
what you wouldn't do where you're some
ethical lines are and the story is great
with regard to that so you really it's
really questioning what you believe in
what you what you wanted what you want
to do what you don't want to do and that
affects the story as well okay fantastic
so am a few more questions for a year so
you've been producing this for both the
Morpheus and oculus together I mean is
that mean if do you have to do have to
design them differently for each unit or
do they just function Kenneth as monitor
is a very surprisingly similar I mean
there are a few differences audio a bit
different than Morpheus at the moment
the control systems actually one of the
biggest challenges at the moment you
know in the Morpheus you've got the
PlayStation they chill shop for for the
PlayStation 4 and that works really well
you can rotate it you can move it around
it's great for tracking on oculus there
isn't an obvious default control
solution at the moment so we kind of
have to support fit mouse and keyboard
which is a real challenge in VR you can
imagine trying to hit traditional keys
and BR with a headset and it's
impossible so you kind of have to stick
to the cursor keys in the space bar
using the mouse mr. pork and shoulders
as well and we're looking at the other
VR control systems as well but that's
what the biggest difference between the
two technically they're very similar and
the actual game runs very very similarly
or both of the metric cool so you
mentioned there's two characters that
you play yeah when you play the assembly
so who are they who are these
how much do you say Madeline stone is is
this female scientist who's kind of
being dragged in so here against her
will era that she's going through
initiation test they're basically
finding out that huh weather should be
right to join this organization and also
telling her about them and then there's
somebody called Joel who is the space
have been working for the assembly for
quite a while and he's starting to
question their morality trying to
question whether they're the
organization he signed up with them as a
few slightly scary things he's noticing
that he's not quite confident about and
I won't say anymore but that's where the
story starts okay okay so this this kind
of really can I gruesome scare alone
means gruesome a dyke tense feel morally
ambiguous science story what was your
inspiration I mean other films have led
you towards this or are the games you
played or you just are you just a fan of
science in general I mean I just figure
away this to come from yeah I think I
think possibly time designing it there
was just Helena's say hacking you know
engineers stuff and there's a little bit
of that the story and you know there's
Google and all the new ice the new tech
companies and we felt like that'd be a
great storyline we wanted to kind of do
a it's like a cult but this is a modern
whole this isn't nicole from the 16th
century dressed in robes that have been
going around for hundreds of years this
is a modern scientific hole and i think
that's a really interesting contrast
okay um so am i would just use your mic
a little bit closer I think anyway am
fact that also is really great um so it
this is not your first your first
experience or developing for for VR
there is it you guys have done something
before is that right well with yeah we
released a demo called skydiving which
was literally something we created in a
48-hour game hack alright that's a game
had thing yeah okay be good fun and we
created it spend a week touching it up
in and out they've got a great reaction
and based on that we decided the arbors
I think for our studio with pivoted to
do PR we've got a few other games and
experiences announced later this year
but the assembly is our first game we're
showing off in the biggest sand we're
really proud of it is it strange like
making a game for a platform that you
know it's still a development and could
change you know what even while you're
trying to build yeah yeah it's a
fascinating and challenging thing
because the hardware is changing with
the software and we're you know we're
getting new builds new versions of the
hardware you things are going in you
think
and we're having to go with that but
that's exciting as well as really
exciting and being part of something
like they are which is so has so much
potential and it's in its infancy and
it's kind of like the early days of
mobile phones with a big brick
telephones you know I think that's kind
of how VR is now wait to see where I was
going to go over the next few years it's
gonna be so exciting so what ya what so
that's an interesting question is like
how far do you think is going to go how
III and five years time how different do
you think is it going to be a lot more
VR do you think yeah I think I think I
think there will be a lot more beer and
they'll be VR and it won't just be
traditional games you want to see games
of the kind that you've played on
playstation or xbox or pc before you'll
see new kinds of experiences and games
are a little bit different and I think
you'll see the headsets evolving a lot
as well you'll seen it coming a lot
smaller I ultimately you know hopefully
the size of a pair of sunglasses and and
yeah I think you'll see your CV are just
just stretching and growing as with
finding our feet we're learning about
this technology we're learning what
works and what doesn't work and I think
that's gonna that's just going to get
better and better as we move forward so
if you could add final question for if
you could em because right now obviously
with oculus amorphouse you got the cam
the the positional camera so you can get
that depth tracking what else if you can
add one more thing one more input what
would you add to like molecules of
Morpheus to free as a game designer what
would you like to see we had tracking
would be more thing I'd love to see
gesture control yes I'm sure they've
been rumors on the web but we don't know
more than you guys about this that
oculus ye do some kind of camera that
will track your hands from the headset
and I think being out Jess or a move and
we and track that kind of stuff really
easily we'll make it will allow you to
do some really brilliant movement
control and stuff like that I think that
would be great that'll make a difference
for kids particularly it means some kind
of standard control system is really
easy to use brilliant well Patrick thank
you so much for coming on stage and for
showing up assembly for the first time
so much so here first guys that was the
assembly it'll be coming out whenever
the heck oculus rift comes out and
project Morpheus land soon as it does
you can play that game the Patrick
thanks again don't go anywhere though
we've got more games tons more games
coming up on this show we got the
witcher 3 very soon as well so stick
around